quand j'explique à mes amis à mes
proches que j'ai j'ai le collier pendant
autant de temps ils me disent mais c'est
pas possible je veux dire tu es jeune tu
aucun antécédent pas paris pour un passé
ont été épargnés
on va pour gagner on n'y a pas de jours
sans symptômes
j'ai pas repris ma vie normale cinq mois
et demi j'aurais jamais pensé que ça
ferait pourtant de temps et je sais la
pac maintenant ça va bien un point
[Musique]
on dépense un dieu comme une grippe du
coup ne suis pas vraiment inquiété et
après même si ses revenus et les scpi
les symptômes qui perd six sont la
tachycardie indies autonomie des
acouphènes surtout à gauche des
problèmes pour digérer les problèmes
cognitifs même respiratoires et des
problèmes dans mes pions c'est un père
biologique de l'enfant ont été des pères
de mémoire ou aux cardiaques
je fais le baril j'avais tellement c'est
la piscine et donc elle est socialement
au moindre effort ce soit puisque on
monte un escalier pour faire un acte
quotidien va dire banale j'habite en
fait les armes n'est même pas un père
eitan les 45 minutes pour réglementer en
métal moi qui voulais faire 80 km en
cours moi qui se trouvait là j'ai sans
problème leur aurait dit on pense tout
aussi mettre un nageur donc tous à ne
plus pouvoir le faire ça montre vraiment
vraiment vraiment les dégâts que pose
cette maladie
pour morgane cruellement réelle prise en
charge et en plus on développe des
problèmes au niveau de différents
organes monde ça veut dire qu'il faut
avoir consulté les différents séminaires
la guerre et malaga cardiologue et c'est
extrêmement fatigant l'art aucune
coordination pour 1 300 le pack potente
renvoient la balle où je me dis
clairement on n'a pas appris à l'école
darif abîmer vos symptômes à une maladie
ne me comprends pas printemps ne connais
pas cette maladie depuis simple a été de
donner des anxiolytiques et
d'antidépresseurs adversaires dans votre
tête
ils on va penser que c'est quelque chose
dont j'ai trouvé les gens me disent mais
c'est pas grave tu es jeune dans ta
juste à bien dormir et puis et puis
après ça va aller mieux mais après c'est
pas le cas
alors les bars
c'était la cérémonie des deux pédiatres
et comment on arrive à bien la
comprendre en fait comment ça pouvait
être que négatif alors que m les
peintres au mondial était de beaucoup de
contenu un peu malade et comme en france
est uniquement sur les sérologies et sur
les anti-pacs on n'étudie pas la réponse
cellulaire des lymphocytes t qui fait
aussi montré en fait quand on est
atteint du premier les prises de
conscience de conscience qui force et en
glucides dans des mondes qui
s'organisent pour essayer de faire
bouger les choses
on attend de voir manquer les actions
c'est à dire qu'avec mon reconnaissent
sur les symptômes cliniques de korrigans
ensuite y ait un protocole pour soi mais
en face c'est quelque chose qu'ils
soient harmonisées entre les hôpitaux
les spécialistes et médecins
généralistes et il faut passablement
dire qu'il ya des morts et cadets
d'hospitalisation aussi compter les
copies dont beaucoup comprennent ce que
c'est il faut une image globale des
décès et des hospitalisations mais aussi
des vies bouleversées
[Musique]